大家早安晚安
歡迎收看這次輪到誰
我是愛倫
OK 經濟台灣股市
從歷史的高點出現了一個相當明顯的回落
上市大概從高點回落13%
那麼上櫃的是跌了大概22%
那面對了這個市場的修正
有人選擇的觀望
有人選擇逢地佈局
但也有不少投資人
目前承受的就是巨大的資金壓力
這幾年隨著台股的行情非常熱絡
市場上非常流行一種叫做
資產活化的操作方式
先是透過房屋增帶
個人信貸或者是股票直接套出了一筆現金之後
再把這筆錢當作自備款去開融資買個股
在揚勤好的時候這種雙層槓桿
當然會讓獲利的陳述是數倍放大的
但是在市場反轉的時候
他也變成了隱形的風險
本週的這次輪到誰呢
我們將從融資的制度的歷史
開始來談起一步步拆解
融資維持率跟維約交割的底線到底在哪裡
以及為什麼當市場開始開槓桿的時候
高檔回落的波動
就會被無情的放大
那麼影片開始之前
記得訂閱我的YT最重要音色的櫃
還有加入官方的LINE8
好首先我們先從最基礎的工具
就是所謂的融資Margin Trading
談起融資的本質
就是你向眷商借錢買股票
你打算買進的股票
去作為抵押品
而自備一部分的資金之後
其餘眷商借給你
這個制度一開始原起於美國
資金已經有百年的歷史了
而且當初的槓桿相當的暴力
我們時間直接回到了1920年代
華爾街的狂熱
當時的融資完全是地下化
而且沒有監管的
而經濟商為了賺取高額的利息
甚至允許投資人指出10%的自備款
就能買進100%價值的股票
也就是高達10倍的槓桿
極度擴張的信用
直接推升了華爾街的泡沫
到了1929年10月
市場迎來歷史性的股市大崩盤
高槓桿的融資引發了連環斷頭賣
拋售潮導致股價是做一個斷額
是下跌
無數的經濟商跟投資人瞬間是破產的
而這場災難讓美國聯準會
在1934年制定了當時著名的T法規
強制將這個融資自備款比例提高至50%
也就是把槓桿鎖定在了兩倍
而台股也延續了這套嚴格的封控體系
目前台股上市股票融資成數最高就是6成
買進100萬的上市股票
你只需要自備40萬
券商會減以60萬
這就是我們常見的
2.5倍基礎的融資槓桿
近年市場不僅僅是使用融資
而是多重的槓桿
就是所謂的槓上槓
就是你在融資買股之前
把借來的錢當做買股的自備款
而通常這個借來的錢
資金來源有大概三種
第一個就是房屋增貸
拿一名下的貸款去抵押
取出現金
第二個則是個人信貸
拿著這個信用或者是說薪資
收入向銀行借出現金
再來第三個
這是股票的直接
已經手上有一些現股的
就像券商直押借出
大概約六成的現金
假設一位投資人
透過了信貸或房貸
取得100萬的現金
作為第一層的資金
接著他再把這100萬元
當作是融資的40%
自備款進場買股
那麼你漲空的資產
就會是100萬出於0.4
就會是250萬元的股票總市值
那麼總負債就會是250萬
包括了是第一層的借款
100萬還有券商的融資
150萬
這個看似其實一樣
你看我們剛提到是2.5倍
這個其實算出來也是2.5倍
但是本質是不一樣的
我們如果用水稻跟水庫來做比喻
一般融資呢
就是你用自家的水庫
去開水渣
就算水位下降呢
你還有水庫底部的緩衝
但是呢如果是雙層的槓桿
就像是你像鄰居借水
拿來當水庫的抵押
而當水渣抽乾就是骨架下跌
你不但要被封鎖水渣
就是融資追繳
隔壁鄰居還要跟你吹桃借水的錢
那這個就是貸款的本息
而當市場出現15%到20%的修正時
第一層貸款的本息現金流壓力
再加上第二層的融資追繳
會同時不向投資人
資產承受力就不會有太多的緩衝空間
再來我們舉一個非常極端的例子
假設這一位投資人手上
有100萬的出使自由資金
那麼第一層我們先去做股票直接
把這100萬去借了60萬出來
再來第二個
他還去申請個人信貸
再套出100萬來
再來第三個
他自己也有房子
拿房產去做偵帶
再借出100萬
這時候投資人手頭上會有60萬的直接
100萬的信貸
100萬的房貸總共260萬
再來他把這260萬借來的資金
當作是自備款
全部開融資進場買股
融資可以買進的總市值
大概就是260萬出於40%
那就是650萬的股票
最終掌控的整體的總資產
有原始限股100萬
再加上融資買進的650萬
總共是750萬元
那麼總負債的金額有直接的60萬
近代的100
房貸的100
融資的319
總共是650萬
真實投入的資產其實只有多少
只有100萬
所以它其實槓桿是750
除以100萬
那會高達的是7.5倍
那麼7.5倍意味的是什麼
就是市場只要下跌13.3%
這7.5倍的波動
就會徹底吞噬掉
投資人最初那100萬的
全部自有淨資產
當然這個是比較少說的例子
只是給大家做一個參考
還有警惕
好 那麼當市場出現回落的時候
金融機構應該怎麼進行封控
這邊給大家兩個必須要搞懂的核心機制
第一個就是融資維持率還有斷頭機制
眷商借錢給你
最怕就是你賠光連眷商的本金都還不上
所以因此眷商會隨時監控你的維持率
那我們一開始的融資維持率
就是股票最新的市值除以融資的借款金額
當你買進股票的時候
維持率大概就會是166.7%
這個就是初始的維持率
而當股價下跌超過22%的時候
維持率就會跌破130%的生命線
這個時候券商就會發出
所謂的追繳通知
如果投資人在T-2內
沒有去補足差額
第三天開盤券商就會強制賣出
這個就是所謂的斷頭
那麼在強制斷頭之後
你賣出的金額連券商
建立了60%本金都不夠還
或者是說投資人
其實進行當充交易是虧錢的
在T-2日上午11點前
交割帳戶如果扣不到款
就會觸發所謂的違約交割
這個會帶來幾個代價
第一個就是信用破產
連真中心會註記3到5年
直接內你不能申請貸款
信用卡也不能開新的證券戶
再來第二個
則會有遇到民事跟財務的精算
券商有權追討最高7%的違約金
強制清算以帳內的其他資產
再來則是會有刑事責任
如果違約金額龐大到會影響到市場的秩序
那會面臨政交法
3年以上10年以下的有期徒刑
講完了這個基本的概念
我們來看一下近期的數據
從2026年6月下旬到7月下旬
這一個月時間
因為大盤高檔這個距離震盪
那麼市場違約的交戈申報金額
出現了非常明顯的升溫現象
我們整理出近期違約交戈的
三大核心數據還有特點
首先
月度累積總申報額
來到了15億到18億元
大概日均就是5000到6千萬
那單日有一個最高峰
就是2026年7月21
申報的金額
高達了2億2千362萬元
是2026年以來
單月的第五高紀錄
那麼分析這些財報數據
會有幾個值得警惕的這個特徵
當沖跟高槓桿爆雷的時候
主要的違約案例呢
會集中在當沖客實力
為能在TJ-2補足這個差額
或者是開了高槓桿
遇到單月爆雷的時候呢
是完全沒有能力去籌儲資金的
那再來指標的熱門標的違約呢
集中在了像是加幣期
這個可能還好
但是下一個大家就非常有感了
就是國劇2327
近期都出現了單一個股被券商
申報數千萬
甚至是上億的集中違約案例
那麼另外還有一個就是
零星違約暴增
除了剛提到大額違約之外
其實近期市場上還出現大量的
帳戶只差幾千塊
就可以交戈的這種散戶違約
這代表的一個狀態
就是近期的股市熱門到
其實有非常多的年輕人
或者是說新手的投資人
風險的觀念確實是有在加強的
為什麼當市場開槓港的人變多的時候
高檔回落的波動會變得如此劇烈
這個背後的機制
其實就是說去槓桿化的負向螺旋
第一個就是資金鏈的雙重級
如果使用直戒再開融資
當大盤回落大概15%
直戒的維持率跟融資的維持率
同時就會告急
如果還使用防戴或者是信貸
每個月本來就要固定去緩本
複習的現金流壓力
會在股票被追繳的時候
是雪上加霜的
再來斷頭賣壓的集中化
當投資源補不出錢
券商未來要自保
所以會在開盤時間集中以市價或跌停價去掛單
砍倉
這種非理性的拋售
並非因為基本面變壞了
而是流動性需要被迫釋放
而市場流動性枯竭
再將連環的爆破
就是當大量斷頭單
同時湧入市場
那接盤的買盤
卻因為觀望而收手
這個時候股票就容易出現
5 量下跌
甚至到5 量跌停
跌停會導致為持率進一步的惡化
那進而再觸發下一批
原本安全的槓桿戶頭跌破130%
就會形成連續斷頭潮
所以當市場拉回跌破138回時率
券商市價砍倉
股價會無量跌停
再引爆下一批的槓桿戶頭跌破
這也是為什麼在去槓桿的過程中
市場的修正往往會呈現速度極快
那速度極大
而且缺乏理性的特徵
槓桿本身就是一種金融工具
它沒有善惡
而在市場順風的時候
它確實能帶動資產做快速的膨脹
但相對的在逆風的時候
可能也會有擴大虧損的影響
而面對近期市場的回落
這邊會有幾個比較理性的
封控建議
首先全面盤點一下
你個人的維持率還有現金率
不要等到收到追繳通知
再來找錢
現在就算在極端的情境之下
那你的總體的維持率會是多少
那每月的薪資跟備用金
是否能夠覆蓋貸款的本息
再來就是主動去這樣幹幹
剩餘去被動補錢
如果資金鏈吃緊
主動撿碼換取現金
就是留的青山寨
那不怕沒才燒
再來尊重市場的周期
還有風險的溢價
那其實真正的投資高手
不是在比誰大漲的時候賺最多
而是比誰在大浪退去時
還能夠留在桌上
而市場的修正總會過去
但前提是你必須確保自己能夠活著
看到光芒
那麼今天的這次輪到誰就到這邊
喜歡影片的朋友記得幫我
訂閱按讚還有開啟小鈴鐺
我們下次見
謝謝大家拜拜